[Musik]
>> MURAT: Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Oh, die Wurst!
Sally! Wasser!
Sally!
>> SALLY: Murat!
>> MURAT: Feuer!
Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
>> SALLY: Murat, ernsthaft?!
>> MURAT: Herzlich willkommen bei Murats 5 Minuten!
Heute gibt es ein richtig geniales Battle
und zwar zwischen Güni und mir.
Mensch gegen Maschine.
Künstliche Intelligenz gegen Plankton.
Hier, herzlich willkommen, Güni!
[Applaus]
Ihr kennt ihn.
Die Einwanderungsbehörde kennt ihn.
>> Güni: Wer ist Plankton?
>> MURAT: Interpol kennt ihn.
>> MURAT: Niemand.
Ja, ich sage es doch nur:
"Mensch gegen Maschine.
Plankton gegen künstliche Intelligenz."
>> Güni: Ja, wer ist Plankton?
>> MURAT: Ich nicht. Du.
Weiter.
So.
Wir machen ein cooles Battle.
Und zwar machen wir was ganz, ganz Einfaches.
Und zwar machen wir einen Strudel.
>> COMPUTER: Strudel.
>> Güni: Was machen wir?
>> MURAT: Und zwar einen Strudel.
>> COMPUTER: Strudel.
>> MURAT: So.
Und zwar machen wir zwei verschiedene Strudel.
Und einmal machen wir einen Strudel auf
süße Art und Variante, wie der Güni das gern mag.
Und wir machen eine richtig geniale herzhafte Variante.
Und nachher lassen wir irgendjemanden,
den wir im Haus finden, probieren.
Und der Verlierer
– was macht der Verlierer?
>> Güni: Der macht sauber.
>> MURAT: Der macht sauber. Ja.
>> Güni: Also du machst sauber.
>> MURAT: Nein.
Auf jeden Fall ein ganz einfaches Rezept.
Was wir natürlich brauchen,
ist als Allerallererstes ein Blätterteig.
Und, da wir jetzt das Ding
nicht unnötig in die Länge ziehen möchten,
haben wir uns einen fertigen Blätterteig geholt.
Einmal für mich
und einmal für Güni.
Tut uns nicht haten,
wenn wir jetzt einen fertigen Blätterteig haben.
Wir sind nicht Sally.
Und deswegen haben wir den fertigen geholt.
So.
Wenn ihr diesen Teig hier habt,
gibt es einen ganz einfachen Weg...
>> Güni: Nein!
>> MURAT: Wenn ihr diesen Teig hier habt,
macht ihr ganz einfach...
>> Güni: Nein!
Du sollst ihn doch erst übereinanderlegen.
>> MURAT: Wie?
>> Güni: Oder nicht?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> Güni: So.
>> MURAT: Wie?
>> Güni: Einklappen.
So.
>> MURAT: Aha.
>> Güni: Doppelt.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> Güni: So.
>> MURAT: Warte kurz.
Stimmt das?
Okay.
So.
Auf jeden Fall...
>> Güni: Der ist so hohl.
>> MURAT: Ich wollte dich nur testen.
Einmal zuklappen.
Und dann weiter?
Erzähl es du mal, dass du auch mal was machst.
>> Güni: Jetzt nimmst du
den Schneider
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> Güni: und schneidest hier
einen Radius dran.
>> MURAT: Aha.
Und ein Radius hat immer welchen Winkel?
>> Güni: Gar keinen Winkel.
Ein Radius ist ein Radius.
>> MURAT: Ah! Ich meine...
Ja.
Wie viel Grad hat ein
>> Güni: Ah! Eben das.
>> MURAT: ein Viertelkreis?
>> MURAT & Güni: 90.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> Güni: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und ein rechter Winkel hat auch
90.
Also ist das das Gleiche, oder?
>> Güni: Ja, deswegen schneiden wir ja die Ecke weg.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Das gibt es doch gar nicht!
Auf jeden Fall machen wir das,
um die Ecken einfach so rund zu machen.
Weil es soll so was wie ein
– der Strudel soll
wie ein Schiffchen aussehen.
So.
Das mache ich jetzt auch. Ich zeige es auch.
Ich mache es ein bisschen professioneller als der Güni.
So.
>> Güni: Und jetzt?
>> MURAT: Jetzt habt ihr hier dieses Schiffchen.
Jetzt kommt was Geniales
Das zeige ich euch.
Und zwar
hier
– Josh, siehst du das?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich kann das nur einmal machen.
Das passiert nur einmal und,
wenn du da nicht dabei bist,
dann passiert es nicht noch mal.
So.
Aber nicht komplett durchschneiden,
sondern hier wieder ansetzen
und wieder.
>> Güni: Die Technik
ist zu beachten, die Technik.
>> MURAT: So.
Oh, ich habe so gerade geschwitzt!
Ich habe es hingekriegt.
Und jetzt kommt was richtig Geniales!
Jetzt passt mal auf, was ich mache.
[Musik]
Hast du es wieder übertreiben müssen, oder?
Wieder mit deiner Kordel?
Okay. Jetzt kommt ein cooler Trick.
Jetzt hält man euch wahrscheinlich
– wenn ihr das jetzt macht, hält man euch
für einen richtigen, coolen Bäcker oder Meisterkoch.
Und zwar: Jetzt nehmt ihr einfach euer Pizzarad.
Ihr könnt auch ein Messer nehmen.
Ihr könnt einen Zahnstocher nehmen.
Und jetzt macht ihr hier so kleine Kerben rein.
Weil, wenn der Teig nachher hier am Rand höher backt,
sieht das richtig aus, als hätte ihr das eigentlich geflochten.
Aber es ist nur ein Trick.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt habe ich es eingeschnitten.
Und jetzt tut man das einfach mit einem Ei bestreichen.
Habe ich irgendwo ein Ei?
Nein.
Ich hole ein Ei.
>> Güni: Mache ich schon mal das Ei.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt haben wir das mit dem Güni
alles eingeschnitten.
Wir haben diese Verkerbungen reingemacht.
Und jetzt nimmt man dieses Ei hier.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Jetzt tut man das Ei, damit bestreichen.
Dann bekommt es einen schönen Glanz.
Da nehmt ihr bitte ein ganzes Ei,
das heißt Eiweiß plus Eigelb.
Folgendes: Jetzt habe ich es mit Ei eingestrichen.
Und jetzt gucke ich wirklich,
dass diese zweite Schicht richtig schön bündig draufsitzt.
Und jetzt tu ich innen drin
noch mal so leicht einschneiden,
damit es auch richtig hochgeht.
Das heißt,
leicht einschneiden.
Ich Idiot habe es durchgeschnitten.
Ich bin so blöd!
So. Wenn ihr das jetzt gemacht habt,
dann tut das in den Backofen.
Folgendes: Jeder Backofen ist verschieden.
Das heißt, was bei mir vielleicht fünf Minuten sein kann
oder zehn Minuten sein kann,
kann bei euch hinterher zehn oder zwanzig Minuten sein.
Kommt immer darauf an.
Deswegen einfach so, bis es so goldbraun ist,
einfach in den Backofen schieben.
Da nehmen wir hier einfach...
>> Güni: Bis es leicht anbräunt.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Da nehmen wir das hier zum Beispiel.
Zack!
Jetzt tu ich es einfach kurz in den Backofen
einfach bei 190°C rein in die mittlere Ebene,
mittlere Schiene.
Zumachen
und
Start.
Und einfach, wenn es ein bisschen goldbraun ist,
wieder rausholen.
Und nachher werden wir es belegen.
Und wenn wir es belegt haben,
dann schieben wir es noch mal rein.
Ganz wichtig
– man kann ja auch mal Fehler zeigen.
Er ist mein größter Fehler.
Das ist der zweite Fehler.
Und zwar der zweite Fehler ist ganz einfach.
Den Blätterteig oben noch mal einstechen.
Wenn ihr ihn nicht einstecht,
dann geht das hoch wie so ein Ballon.
Das heißt, ganz kurz, bevor ihr ihn reinschiebt, einstechen.
So.
Seht ihr das? Josh, siehst du das?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und jetzt einfach kurz ein bisschen einstechen,
dass es nicht hochgeht.
So. Während unsere Blätterteigstrudel
schon mal vorbacken,
bis sie goldgelb sind,
tun wir schon mal unsere Füllung vorbereiten.
Also, wie gesagt, ich mache herzhaft,
der Güni macht süß.
>> Güni: Belag.
>> MURAT: Belag, genau.
Und
ich habe euch
– ich will euch auch keine Zutaten nennen.
Nehmt einfach alles, was ihr im Kühlschrank habt.
Das heißt...
>> Güni: Was ihr gerne esst.
>> MURAT: Was ihr gerne esst, genau.
Der Güni...
Ganz, ganz wichtig:
Der Grund ist eigentlich hier das.
>> Güni: Schmand.
>> MURAT: Schmand. Genau.
Wie beim Flammkuchen auch.
Ich habe hier Schmand.
Den könnt ihr überall kaufen im Supermarkt.
Dann habe ich noch im Kühlschrank
ein bisschen Schnittlauch gefunden.
Den finde ich auch richtig cool.
Dann habe ich
– das ist jetzt keine Produktplatzierung.
Ich bekomme kein Geld dafür.
Ich mag den unheimlich!
Das ist Gazi Käse.
Das ist eine Kaşar-Käse.
Der kommt auch rein.
Der sorgt noch mal für eine richtig coole cremige Konsistenz.
Und der ist selber nicht zu mächtig.
Also der Käse ist nicht so mächtig,
dass er nachher
zum Beispiel meine Wurst übertönt.
So.
Dann habe ich hier noch mal was von Gazi.
Wieder keine Produktplatzierung.
Ich mag meinen
– das ist mein Lieblingskäse, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Das ist ein Nomadenkäse
Der gibt dem so eine gewisse Würze mit rein.
Rieche mal.
So.
Auf jeden Fall richtig cool!
Und was ich natürlich auch dran mache, ich tu noch
– hier
habe ich noch ein bisschen Salami
im Kühlschrank gefunden.
Die tu ich auch noch rein.
Riecht richtig cool!
>> Güni: Ist das Schweinesalami?
>> MURAT: Nein. Das ist Rindersalami
und die ist 100 Prozent halal.
So.
Weißt du, was halal ist?
Ja, nicht halalala. Genau.
>> Güni: Hallaluja!
>> MURAT: So. Genau.
Was ich auch habe, ist hier
– noch drauf mache.
Das gibt die besondere Würze.
Das ist Öz Pastırma.
Das ist ein...
Der wird in Wiesbaden hergestellt,
ist ein richtig cooler
– wie Pastrami.
Pastırma, Pastrami ist ein Rinderschinken.
Mit Bockshornklee außenrum.
Oh, das gibt einen richtigen Geschmack!
Und während ich das gerade
alles erzählt habe,
habe ich gemerkt, dass dir
das Wasser im Mund zusammengelaufen ist.
Habe ich recht?
Genau.
>> Güni: Bockshornklee?
>> MURAT: Genau.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach hier
den Pastrami hier einfach
und schneide den einfach ein bisschen auseinander.
>> Güni: Jetzt wolltest du ja wieder ganz cool sein, gell?
So.
>> MURAT: Ja, ja. Ist das aufgefallen?
Hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Hat nicht funktioniert, gell?
Mein Gott!
Dass dir...
Weißt du was? Immer so was Doofes
fällt dir immer als Erstes auf.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
>> Güni: Du bist zu blöd zum Schinkenschneiden!
>> MURAT: Ach?
>> Güni: Hast du dir das mal überlegt?
>> MURAT: Okay.
Jetzt nehmen wir hier
– ich mag einfach,
ich sage es euch ehrlich,
ich mag einfach Wurst unheimlich.
>> Güni: Ja, man sieht es.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
So. Okay.
>> Güni: Habe ich kapiert.
>> MURAT: Güni, jetzt musst du die machen süß.
Erklär du noch, was du dazu machst.
>> Güni: Ja, ich mache meinen Schmand.
Dann
Himbeeren einkochen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> Güni: Und das dann darauf verteilen.
Und dann kommt noch
Zucker
>> MURAT: Zimt?
>> Güni: und Zimt.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Und du machst jetzt was noch, Güni?
>> Güni: Himbeeren einkochen.
>> MURAT: Die Himbeeren einkochen?
>> Güni: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
[Musik]
>> Güni: Wir erhitzen jetzt die Himbeeren.
Einkochen.
Jetzt kommt der Zucker dazu
und wird schön verrührt.
>> MURAT: Jetzt ist es schon goldbraun.
Ich hole jetzt unsere Backbleche raus.
Für mich und ich hole deins auch gleich raus,
wenn ich dabei bin.
>> Güni: So. Hier einmal gucken.
Das ist jetzt so weit fertig eingekocht.
>> MURAT: Güni, guck mal. Ich habe es schon hier.
Guckt mal. Man sieht auch hier, schön goldbraun.
Das reicht schon vollkommen aus.
>> Güni: Und jetzt so.
>> MURAT: Das waren jetzt insgesamt
– bei mir hat es wirklich nur zehn Minuten gedauert.
>> Güni: Ja, wenn es anfängt, braun zu werden.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> Güni: Das sieht man ja
an der Eikruste außenrum.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Richtig.
So. Jetzt ganz, ganz einfach.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach diesen Schmand.
Das mache ich jetzt hier drauf
und verteile es jetzt richtig schön.
Wird richtig schön cremig.
Güni, du musst mir einen Gefallen tun.
Das muss jetzt auch gut aussehen.
Also das heißt, wenn wir Fotos machen,
muss es auch schön sein.
[Musik]
>> Güni: Ja, dann darfst du aber nicht drauf auf die Bilder.
>> MURAT: Ein Becher hat jetzt vollkommen gereicht hier.
Und jetzt nehme ich richtig cool den Belag
und tu den richtig schön verteilen.
Und das geht saumäßig schnell!
Ich glaube auch, dass das allgemein schneller geht als Pizza.
Findest du nicht, Güni?
>> Güni: Jawoll.
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt natürlich nach Belieben noch
ein bisschen Pfeffer.
Wenig Salz, weil das Pastrami hat schon sein eigenes Ding.
>> Güni: Ja, aber...
>> MURAT: Nur ein bisschen.
Gerade wegen dem Schmand,
weil der Schmand so ziemlich neutral ist.
[Musik]
>> Güni: Ja, deine...
Hör auf!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt nehmen wir es mal
und tun es noch mal in den Backofen.
Vielleicht gerade
– ich tu es so lange,
bis der Käse richtig schön verschmolzen ist.
Vielleicht auch wieder,
weil der Backofen ist schon heiß,
noch mal vielleicht fünf Minuten.
Güni, du tust auch noch mal vielleicht noch fünf Minuten.
Und dann holen wir es raus.
Und dann holen wir wirklich eine
unabhängige Person,
die dann probiert.
Und dann werden wir sehen,
wer hier der Bessere ist, okay?
Mensch gegen Maschine.
Künstliche Intelligenz gegen Plankton.
Okay?
>> Güni: Einzeller.
>> MURAT: Einzeller.
Ja, okay.
Zack, rein.
Wieder bei 190°C.
[Musik]
Power.
>> Güni: So. Aus dem Weg.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
Das Foto ist jetzt schon geschossen.
Güni.
So.
Und jetzt muss es aber völlig fair sein.
Du darfst auch natürlich
nicht irgendwelche Anspielungen machen und sagen:
"Ich habe das oder das gemacht."
>> Güni: Nee, nichts.
>> MURAT: Okay. Und jetzt tun wir zwei Leute holen,
zwei Leute, die unparteiisch sind,
>> Güni: Ja.
>> MURAT: weil sie auch nicht wissen, wer es gemacht hat.
Also herzlich willkommen,
Sally und Alex!
Okay?
Ihr probiert jetzt
und sagt jetzt
– ihr müsst jetzt nicht sagen:
"Hier das eine ist ja süß und das andere ist herzhaft."
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ihr probiert einfach und sagt,
welches euch besser geschmeckt hat.
>> SALLY: Aber eigentlich kann man es ja nicht vergleichen,
weil eins ist süß, eins herzhaft.
>> ALEX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Die Spielregeln mache ich!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Aber ich muss sagen, sieht beides voll gut aus!
>> MURAT: Gell?
Und ich muss auch sagen, es ist extrem einfach.
Es ist eine einfache Resteverwertung, weil
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: ich habe die Zutaten jetzt nicht extra eingekauft.
Wir hatten sie im Kühlschrank.
Und...
>> SALLY: Willst du das Pizzarad?
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Schere?
>> SALLY: Pizzarad?
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
Schere ist...
>> SALLY: Güni.
>> Güni: Och!
>> MURAT: Guck mal! Jetzt fängt der schon wieder an!
>> Güni: Heieiei!
>> MURAT: Hast du gesehen?
Der hat mich die ganze Zeit provoziert!
>> SALLY: Mein Pizzarad liegt nicht da.
>> MURAT: Ja. Siehst du? Deswegen Schere.
>> Güni: Guck mal in der anderen Schublade drinnen.
>> MURAT: Passt auf. Kein Problem.
Ich nehme das Nakiri Messer
und werde es jetzt durchschneiden.
>> Güni: Was für ein Messer? Harakiri?
>> MURAT: Nein! Naka-
Guck mal. Der provoziert mich.
>> Güni: Das soll
>> SALLY: Oder magst du eher?
>> Güni: zum Probieren sein.
>> ALEX: Nee, danke.
>> MURAT: Da.
>> ALEX: Danke schön.
>> MURAT: Warte. Und für das andere
hole ich ein anderes Messer,
damit es den Geschmack nicht verfälscht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> Güni: Oh!
>> MURAT: Was für ein Zufall, dass ich noch
das neue Santoku 1,4 Volt
gefunden habe.
So.
>> Güni: Ach Gott, bist du blöd!
>> MURAT: Aha.
>> Güni: Das gibt es doch gar nicht, 1,4 Volt.
>> MURAT: Das war eine Produktplatzierung!
Mein Gott!
>> Güni: Ja, aber 1,4 Volt.
Wer soll dir denn das abnehmen?
>> ALEX: Richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Dann nimm mal hier.
Das ist
– schmecke selber raus, was da drin steckt.
>> Güni: Schmeckt ja wirklich gut, gell?
>> SALLY: Mh. Darf ich spülen?
>> MURAT: Nein!
>> ALEX: Müsste man.
>> Güni: Doch!
>> MURAT: Nein, nein! Nee, dann tut ihr ja
den Geschmack verfälschen.
>> Güni: Ah, nee!
>> MURAT: Ach so!
Wie schmeckt es?
Auch gut?
>> SALLY: Nach Zimt.
>> Güni: Ja.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und Himbeeren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> Güni: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was richtig gut noch drauf wäre?
>> MURAT: Was?
>> SALLY: So karamellisierte Mandelstücke.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Weißt, von deinen gebrannten Mandeln,
hacken und dann noch draufstreuen.
>> Güni: Oh!
>> MURAT: Auf den Gedanken
kommt ein Einzeller natürlich nicht.
>> SALLY: Guck.
>> MURAT: Ah! Stimmt!
Okay, haben wir vergessen.
Also, ihr zwei, jetzt bitte....
Jetzt habt ihr ja
>> SALLY: Sehr lecker!
>> MURAT: beides gegessen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Jetzt eine ehrliche Meinung.
Was hat euch jetzt besser gefallen?
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> MURAT: Nein, jetzt bitte auch nicht
– es gibt nicht: "Alle haben gewonnen.
Hauptsache, es macht Spaß."
Darum geht es nicht.
>> SALLY & ALEX: Doch!
>> MURAT: Es geht um gewinnen oder verlieren.
>> Güni: Du hast verloren.
>> SALLY: Erster Gang,
zweiter Gang.
>> Güni: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay. Wer hat jetzt gewonnen?
>> ALEX: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ALEX: Deftig: Hauptgang.
Nachspeise.
>> SALLY: Und ich kann optisch nicht sagen,
was ich schöner finde, weil beide schön sind.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ihr habt beide gewonnen.
>> Güni: Komm in meine Arme.
>> MURAT: Das ist nicht fair!
Alex, mal ehrlich.
Das hat doch cooler geschmeckt, oder?
>> SALLY: Das ist halt würzig und das ist der Nachtisch.
>> MURAT: Ja, also. Dann gebt es doch zu!
Also es war schön und jetzt:
Wer ist jetzt der King?
Du kannst auch Papa zu mir sagen.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall ganz klar gewonnen,
weil sie es nicht zugeben möchten,
weil sie immer irgendwie gegen mich sind, alle drei.
Ich habe gewonnen.
So.
>> SALLY: Du hast welchen gemacht?
Den?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay?
>> SALLY: Ich finde beide gut.
>> MURAT: Also ich schüttle mir selber die Hände.
Danke.
>> Güni: Na, schüttle ruhig.
>> MURAT: So. Hat Spaß gemacht,
mit Güni heute wieder zu kochen.
Aua! Güni, hör auf!
So.
Macht es gut!
Tschüss!
[Musik]